let's review we've done differentiation
haven't we so let's get that on the
board you're learning something new
you're always connected to what you know
before
so the community when we're thinking
just
of e to the x
what's that equal to just the derivative
e to the x good we're awake already
fantastic
so therefore that tells you that
the integral of ndx
with respect to x is going to be
e to the x plus x plus your constant
okay so there's your building block okay
let's extend it just a little bit
we already noticed that just like the
derivative of the
special exponential function is back
itself
if we would differentiate say 2 to the x
you're off by that factor aren't you
so all right i think if i were to
integrate it
what would happen raise your hand if you
could tell me straight away right now
anyone okay so let's pause and let's
think about it okay
you know obviously uh it's not going to
go straight back to
the x just like e to the x d okay
but it's going to be close isn't it how
can we use what we've written
here to take advantage of that
how can we use that like we used it here
from here to here
it's a straight line here here it's not
quite a straight line there's something
extra we're going to have to do
what should we do any takers
okay so you're suggesting some division
all right what
okay now the question is why all right
how can we actually
show that that's the case i'd go back to
our first line so i'm going to actually
write this off
okay
now what i've got here is this being
differentiated gives you that
okay so that means if i integrate this
that'll take me here yes that's okay
but i don't want to integrate this i
want to integrate something a little
different
i want to integrate that without the log
2. log 2 is no problem though because
it's just a constant
right so it's a constant coefficient if
we're 3 or 4 would give us the issues
it just looks weird so therefore what do
i have to do
i've got to divide both sides by log two
so
slap your log two over there
okay so far so good right and don't
forget that when you just have a
constant coefficient
okay suppose i said what's a half
of the derivative of x
okay so that's really a half of 1
so that's a half isn't it the way
differentiation works is that with
constant coefficients
you can bring them in and out as you
please because they don't depend on x
okay so really this is the same as
what's the derivative of
a half x
okay you're asking the same question
okay so therefore what i can do here is
one on log two
and do exactly the same sort of thing
this is the derivative of one on log two
times two dx
okay following so far all right now
quick question before i write this down
um
maybe two quick questions what's that
not trick question it's 3x
plus c okay so what's that
okay good all right what's this
okay good keep in your head
over here i'm going to integrate okay so
i'll integrate both sides but i'm going
to do it a little slower usually i'd say
integrate with respect to x okay i'm
just going to
integrate i'm not actually going to
describe
which variable because in some sense i
don't have to all right watch
i don't need to go here
that looks weird we'll fix it in a
second okay
the problem with it is really the right
hand side because i'm integrating but
it's like integrate
what i don't really know but the
equation actually supplies to us
what we're going to integrate with
respect to because it's right there
isn't it
okay if you liked i could have done it
on this line here
and multiplied through by dx
and then integrate okay so do that
okay so this is what i checked with you
before
we've got the right hand side that's
actually what i wanted the integral of
2x with respect to x
what's the left-hand side
you told me that the integral of dx is x
for c
the integral of d theta is theta plus c
what would be the integral of d y
how long how long do i need to play this
game for
this is the integral of d that
i know and that i know you're not used
to it's just used to you know one
variable but
you can do whatever you like that
variable there y for instance or theta
or x
is just short for you know usually y
would be a whole function like the x or
something like that
okay so just like here right
you're going to get that
plus your constant okay that's the
integral
there you go no problem all right now
therefore
when you're having a go at let's have a
look just let's do an um
let's do a definite integral really
quickly
just to make sure we're all on the same
page let's go back to ease
so
nice easy one to dig in okay when you
integrate you actually just
find the primitive function just like
before we said you're going to get e to
the x okay
what do the zero and the one mean what
do they actually tell us to do
i'm going to have to yeah i heard it we
have to put it in i'm going to
substitute
these are the values that i'm going to
evaluate values i'm going to evaluate
the function
at yeah okay so e to the one minus
is zero okay so e minus one
there i'm done okay so everything you're
gonna do
in this exercise is a variation on that
theme um sometimes you'll see
they'll put in different bases but it's
not that confusing you're just off by a
constant
okay so just divide through by whatever
is appropriate all right